erwartete riesige explosion zur ein
erfolg das stimmt
ja
pauli
die heilige exkursion zum ende der karte
halleluja
ich wollte sein mega projekt der epic
komplett zusammen mit komme und lasst
doch erstmal schlafen legen
eigentlich geht das nicht eure daten and
roll band kaputt oder was hier geht
wahrscheinlich nicht erwarten dass wir
hier mit schampus drüber das macht spaß
ach verdammt und weiter kommt man dann
auch wieder nicht wir sterben eni oder
haben nie irgendwelche probleme mit der
map deswegen brauchen wir auch so einen
schalter für nach allein schon wir
spielen die jedem app eigentlich von dem
die neue rauskommen aber wir zählen
eigentlich bei jeder karte auch einige
fliegen dauerhaft eng wie es gibt immer
in welchem er spielt trotzdem ja seit
jahren wird sich ist ja eben und vor
allem weil ihr das auch gut finde ich
komme da auch übrigens hat gar nicht
drüber
das schaffe ich ja noch hier aber den
danach die sprünge hier nach diesen okay
ich hab's geschafft und den nein sagt
ich bin komplett runter aber nicht ich
auch ich habe aber noch eine lore soll
ich mal der gott benutzen sie fertigt
falsche richtung
ich bin schon wieder oben
eine junge mutter ja ich war aber mit
dem mark meinhardt jetzt einfach ist
aber noch kurz ein löffel vom 11
ich schaffe es ich schaffe es cool ich
habe übrigens mittlerweile 20 punkte und
die hälfte der 10 11 11 tote fische
sterben
du hast auf die mega heftige ausrüstung
her ein carport er sich mal wieder immer
wieder im falle des bodens endlich im
flugzeug man ja hier immer ausreden
dafür michler konsulat bei mir werden
wir schon gerade wird truhen übersehen
nicht einmal weitere tun finden wir ja
ich auch okay da kommt bestimmt werden
transportband ok größten techno tempel
von unten also hier kommen wir nicht
lange müssen wir wohl hier lang
wo du gerade bist man muss schon hier
lang weil hier kommt ein langer weg und
hier kommt nicht rüber irgendwie dann
kann man ja da kommt man jedoch über
warte mal ich hab schon weg okay der
ganz schlaue ja natürlich so und
lagerbecken dachte sachen
das tnt kommst du mit hinter mir
das schade stark gemacht hatte ich freue
mich selbst fall einfach mit 88
ich dachte er wäre viel größer aber
allein hat erstmals rodelfans vor allem
wickelt die einfach mal 9000 andere
haben wir noch schalter jedoch und
krippengruppen krippengruppe du kannst
dich ja besonders gut aus auch open
scheiße ich höre sie nur noch zwischen
nein bin gestorben
verdammt und jetzt hast du bist schon
'was machst dann auch endlich weg ein
herz
wir kommen gerade relativ gut voran es
immer das gleiche bei deinen folgen
kommen wir immer gut voran und beim
reicht manchmal ja weil ich da nicht
auch mal ganz viel scheiße machen alter
mann nicht so viel sport ja klar komme
getting closer to rio am ok go global
tech i werde das sprachrohr der zugabe
weißt du überhaupt nicht aber ich noch
nie gehört irgendwie immer du willst du
durch mit tomaten gegessen mit tomaten
und männern reisen mit megapascal aber
okay ich bin auch schon bald tot
eine rüstung geht anscheinend auch
wieder dem ende zu
das ist ja dann hier auf darunter
gefallen einfach beide bei runterfallen
okay nun wieder hoch und darauf an
ja ich hab's
ich bin gestorben wie kann hier sterben
wollt ihr auch gerne fragen
das wall street journal
ich höre monster ich wurde irgendwie
teleportiert oder so
neulich auch hey bist du tot du musst
einfach nur stehen bleiben ich mit geld
gibt du musst nur stehenbleiben alter
wie geil ist das denn bitte für ultras
bonpoint check das ist eine falle habe
ich schon gedrückt runter gefallen kann
zwar vielleicht kommt oder so wer den
jackpot hier an sich macht dass er
nächste alter es gibt doch gut ab wie
sowas denn wie hoch man damit springen
kann
nein nein nein ich werde sterben ja ich
bin gestorben wie eigentlich immer aber
gut macht auch überhaupt nichts nein ich
heiße party mich zu dir und du fällst
auch unter aber das schöne ist weg ich
war mir diesmal spawn freund alter wird
es trotzdem krass vor allem wie schnell
man da ist es geschafft cool
naja aber ein nein ja aber ich bin auch
immer noch so schnell von vorhin ich hab
immer noch mit 53 er geschwindigkeit das
ist so verdammt was man dir denn normal
ich schaffte den sprung nicht weil ich
immer darauf von hand aufkommen
hallo hier bin ich im pay-tv man gute
frage
du musst die flipflops anziehen habt ihr
nicht fiktiv speed fahren wenn ich im
creative mode ich bin auch so wenn man
drüber läuft zu meinem creative entfällt
auf japan
damit man wieder hochkommt aber nicht
damit man darüber fliegen können wie du
manchmal wenn ich will nicht über ich
ständig nur wieder hier auf dieses
komische wollten allerdings hatte wie
schnell wir da einfach mal durch grant
altern ein chip ist das schwierig ich
bin auch hier runter gefallen runter
gefallen bist okay ich habe es geschafft
habe ich nicht aber schade olympia-norm
weg bin bei dir wird immer geflogen der
folge gar nicht dass ich bin schon die
ganz oft geschah ist einfach seine
angewohnheiten runterfällt direkt.de und
nach oben zu drücken sie dann zu
teleportieren
das stimmt ok weiter weiter weiter
weiter hier im schaugeschäft versteht ja
von knopf auf dem auf dem schild preis
debatten vor checkpoint wissen nicht
gestorben
weiter geht's mit suisse alle einfach an
hätten nein ich gehe ich doch einfach
durch abschließbare noch ein creative
natürlich auch ich heute alles kann ja
ich habe auch schon fast alles kaputt
gehauen
egal weitergehe lolo okay wenn wir
nochmal ich auch warum passt macht der
schalter der tür
langsam ist mal wieder punkte glaube ich
kommt aber ich so ein gefühl
ich glaube einfach an allen vorbei alter
halt ich spring daher und ich sehr froh
tnt ich auch nein girlfriend kuchen
feuer zu alter was wir haben auch keine
schilder geräten einfach com ist weg
weil ich das ehrlich ich weiß nicht ob
er das sieht dann kommen wir gleich
steht komme hde verlässt den server ich
mein ganzes kreatives und so bewegen
es liegt nicht an mir
klasse internet yeah yeah
und jetzt kommt das worauf wir alle
gewartet habt ich zünde dieses tnt an
bergab
guck mal freunde von mir
schaut mal dass in meine freunde meine
freunde ein girlfriend
girlfriend mein girlfriend
3coms offline
ich rufe ihn man konnte keine verbindung
herstellen
ich weiß nicht was mit mir los ist
vielleicht gestorben oder hatte hunger
und hat sich selbst aufgegessen oder
irgendwie sowas
komisch komisch hier noch ein löffel
kurz aus meinen salat spontan so
warum
ich hoffe noch mal an wenn du jetzt
nicht an einer ganz kurzen stopp
combe komme noch
halo high enough erweckt
mein computer ist abgestürzt aber zum
glück habe ich ja nicht aufgenommen ja
das gut weißt du in meinem zimmer hier
nimmst noch auf ich nehme noch offen da
noch mittendrin also mein zimmer ist ihr
so warm dass gab es bei euch hell wie
viele punkte hast du ich habe elf nur
okay du hast gewonnen' von den punkten
her aber hier sind ganz vielen tieren
ganz viel feuerzeuge
deswegen komme bitte auf den server oder
mit sehr einfachen nach erhalt show
vorbei und da möchtest dir ja ist schon
vorbei
nein leider nicht ich möchte darf das
anziehen komme ja klar warte mal cp
wartet eine riesige explosion zur ein
erfolg
ob das stimmt weiß ich die komplette
karte ja was na ja quatsch
die riesige explosion zum ende der karte
aber das tnt steckt die anderen teams
nicht an wenig doch doch schon drei soll
guck mal wie sich das verbreitet alter
das brennt sich durch die heiligen
ja
schon das war
die halte die exkursion zum ende der
karte
nein also dass ich bin ich durchgelaufen
hier steht
let's just where i ventures alles weil
da hinten warnschilder scart vorbei also
da wo wir einfach her gelaufen sind
ok ich warte hier woran standen hier
glaube ich dir einfach mal
wie laut das auch ist sich würdig kommen
jump abwehr zum claim your app award
also springt hoch damit er dein epischen
eine epische belohnung bekommen sobald
wir das gemeistert haben ok und von
daher hat er wirklich war die karte
etwas kleiner etwas etwas kürzer als die
karte davor aber macht ja auch überhaupt
nichts also ich es schön und knackige
grapel und aller karten von jetzt
irgendwie schön also not eigentlich
wieder 1 ja auf jeden fall also ich habe
auch nichts zu meckern wir auch nichts
zu meckern
wir kommen und ich habe ja auch überlegt
ob wir den etwa die etwa modifikation
machen soll ja genau
da gab es allerdings eine menge bugs und
fehler deswegen haben wir jetzt gesagt
dass wir das erstmal nicht machen weil
ich weiß dass nur der flug place und
veronika das glaub ich gemacht
ja genau an gespielt auch noch mal nicht
ja genau die haben auf jeden fall alle
aufgehört bzw 0 ab und zu deren aufgabe
weil er halt relativ viele bugs drin
sind wir erst mal gesagt dass wir erst
mal warten oder halt das erstmal nicht
machen und dann erstmal diese map hier
machen und sonst könnt ihr uns auch
einfach wünsche oder andere sachen die
wir eventuell machen sollen einfach
unten in die kommentare schreiben
und dann werden wir uns daran
orientieren genau wer irgendwie weniger
sinnvoll gewesen hätten wir sage ich mal
ein mod gespielt der rumba cd- und nicht
wirklich viel bietet und erwarten werden
lieber ein bisschen und haben gesagt
halte york gut wir erst mal die karte
und wir warten allgemein noch mal ein
bisschen wegen dem mord vielleicht
machen wir doch mal vielleicht machen
wir die modifikation noch wie genau die
ich falsch sagt immer ich habe mir damit
die angewöhnt das ja eigentlich
natürlich gut
labbadia geschah damals hat auch noch
keiner dagegen so richtig fand auch das
klang auch viel besser das aber auch
einfach viel besser aber naja alter
komme ich jetzt schon momentan das
battle viele sagen bestimmt es heißt die
mod die heutigen wm ort ja immer noch
der mode eigentlich sagen wegen der
moderator für das spiel aber viele leute
sagen und ich weiß nicht ich hab jetzt
die angewöhnt eine neue mode also wir
warten auf jeden fall bis die mod etwa
zwei komplett fertig ist dann machen wir
das vielleicht dann schauen uns das an
sonst wenn ihr sonst welche karten habt
oder so können das auch in die
kommentare schreiben
und dann werden
uns da eventuell daran setzen sonst die
welterfolge habt ihr alle bäume gesehen
und das war es jetzt mal von seiner von
meiner seite aus und irgendwas sagen
willst dann kannst du es jetzt sagen
hallo hallo bin ich jetzt auf youtube in
der partie bei pommes ist wie ihr bald
fertig wie gut dann wäre das wirklich
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann lasst
wirklich gerne einen hoch da für die
schönen knackige staffel von der epic
games die war ja wirklich hammer und
dann haut rein und schön mit ciao